i think you'll find this video exciting
because until now we've just been
talking about the federal reserve and
the abstract and i was drawing little
boxes to represent balance sheets but
this is the actual federal reserve
balance sheet and i took a date that was
before all of this silliness started
happening in the banking sector just so
we could kind of see what it happened
what a federal reserve balance sheet
would have looked like in a normal
environment and then we can actually
in future videos compare what they've
done since then and then we can get a
better insight into all of the different
machinations that the federal reserve
has done to kind of try to keep banks
liquid and solvent and to keep
everything going and we can debate
whether they've been good or bad or
they're just keeping banks in kind of
zombie mode but anyway this is this is
the federal reserve's balance sheet as
of february 14
2007 so before all the craziness
happened although a little bit started
this was before the fed started taking
really aggressive action to to
provide liquidity for the markets but
here are the assets so first of all we
have the total assets number and that's
just interesting to look at 870 these
are all in millions so this is 871
billion
dollars of assets so let's just get the
big picture there's 871 billion on
assets let me draw that here in our
traditional box
diagram
so if i were to draw the assets
this is the assets
the sum of all the assets
over here
is
billion dollars
and we know that the liabilities plus
equity better add up to 871 billion
let's see what's the total liabilities
total liabilities is 839
billion so give or take 840
so the liabilities i'll do in a
different color
the liabilities
are 840 billion give or take a little
bit
actually it should be they should have
the same width not that the width
matters that much but they should be
look
so the liability should be 840
840 billion and then whatever is left
over should be equity right assets minus
liabilities what you have minus what you
owe is
is what you what you're left with for
the owners and of course owners of the
federal reserve you kind of have to take
with a grain of salt they really don't
have the upside of traditional owners
they're really just kind of
stakeholders
what's left over is the equity it should
be roughly 31 billion
31 billion of equity and let's confirm
that by looking at the actual balance
sheet
and here we have it total capital is
31 billion so big picture it so far it's
kind of meeting up with how we've
envisioned a federal reserve balance
sheet but let's dig a little deeper and
see if we can find interesting things
and things we've talked about and
and
hopefully at this point we should
actually understand all of it all of the
lines of the federal reserve so let's
focus on the assets for now so the
assets are just
this part of it
okay so it has
this is what this is 11 billion of gold
certificate accounts that's some type of
rights on gold
see gold certificate accounts let's see
if they have any other gold anywhere
coin
one billion but it is all small potatoes
right i don't know what special drawing
right certificate account is but it's
very small relative to the big pie right
there's 871
billion of assets this is just kind of
almost rounding off error here we have a
big chunk of something actually i think
this 11 billion is actual gold because i
don't see it anywhere else on their
assets so i think but if you combine
roughly i don't know what this this
thing here is but if you combine this
and this it's saying that the federal
reserve is
because i don't see gold anywhere else
here
that it's holding roughly 12 billion
dollars worth of gold which really isn't
a lot of gold when you consider the
total size of its balance sheet
the big piece
right here let me pick a different color
i'll do it in the purple
the has securities repurchase agreements
and loans
808 billion so almost 809 billion so
this is a big piece of the fed's balance
sheet you know out of the whole
out of the whole 871 808 so pretty much
it's like you know it's almost like that
much of it
actually maybe a little bit less of that
there are these securities and things
like that let's see what kind of
securities they have and they break them
down so this 808 billion is made up of
these things right here
the bulk of them are u.s treasury loans
right so these are going to be bills
notes and bonds and okay so just explain
a treasury bill and i've done videos on
this this is essentially a us a loan to
the government for a year or less so
it's just a a loan to the government
that matures in a year or in three
months notes and bonds these are loans
to the u.s treasury that have longer
maturities notes are up to 10 years
bonds are more than 10 years
and then inflation index bonds i'll do a
whole video on that in the future but
these are essentially treasuries that
are indexed to inflation so you can kind
of hedge out a little bit of your
inflation risk but needless to say the
big picture is is that
780 billion of the fed's assets are
treasuries
loans to the federal government so let
me just draw that here so you know a
pretty pretty big piece roughly
you know that much
is treasury so most of what the what of
what the federal reserve owns are
treasuries and that's consistent with
everything we've gone over so far and
that accounts for everything up to here
and then what's interesting what we just
talked about repurchase agreements 30
billion
repurchase agreements
and i don't know 100 percent but i'm
guessing that these are someone came to
the discount window and essentially
borrowed 30 billion dollars
from the fed it's not just someone is
probably multiple people came and
borrowed 30 billion dollars from the fed
and they gave treasuries as collateral
but as we know just the way repurchase
agreements work they actually kind of
sold the treasuries to the fed and the
federal agreed to buy it later but it's
essentially collateral so these
repurchase agreements they're included
in these security in these securities
because they're not just agreements
right there actually are they're
probably treasuries or they might be
other types of highly rated securities
and we'll learn in in future videos that
the fed has lowered its standards over
the last year as in terms of what type
of collateral or what type of securities
it's willing to trade in these
repurchase agreements but in this
situation looks like about 30 billion
dollars and you can also you know you
give a clue of what repurchase
agreements are because here they say
is held outright
right so there's nothing there's no
repurchase agreement they're not there's
not there's not some contract where they
say they're going to sell this to
someone else at a another price it but
these are repurchase agreements so that
these are kind of more collateral for
loans and then they have outright loans
49 million that's pretty much peanuts in
the federal reserve world so the bulk is
treasuries a little bit of repurchase
agreements and then there's other assets
they don't break out what this is maybe
there's some gold in that i'm not sure
bank premises the buildings of the
federal reserve are worth two billion
dollars i mean they have was 12 banks
around the country and i'm sure they
have a bunch of other things so and then
items in process collection i don't know
what these things are but these are all
small potatoes the big thing is the
federal reserves assets are
predominantly u.s treasuries at least to
predominantly treasuries right now
now let's look at the liabilities and to
some degree this is much more
interesting
so federal reserve notes net of federal
reserve bank
holdings federal reserve notes so
federer's at 769
billion dollars so when i talked about
notes outstanding that's what this is
these are federal reserve
notes that have been printed and they're
liabilities right because the federal
reserve bank printed these notes and
then used them as currency and so
they're liabilities now because someone
can come back another time and say hey
give me
back the you know the value of these
things and that's a bit of an abstract
concept but roughly i don't know 700
something of this
are notes outstanding this is money that
the federal reserve had printed
and then the there's some reverse
repurchase agreement which essentially
for some reason the federal reserve use
repurchase agreements to borrow from
someone else
it has a little bit of deposits
right and these deposits have actually
grown dramatically in this pat in the
past year has 22 billion dollars of
deposit so these are actually deposits
that banks are keeping with the federal
reserve
the u.s treasury actually keeps
some money there depository institutions
have 17 billion and actually that's how
the federal reserve traditionally has
paid its expenses is that people put
deposits with the federal reserve so
let's say that these are deposits from
banks it's not it's a very small piece
it's like 17 billion
these could be deposits from member
banks but the federal reserve does not
pay interest in these deposits
they don't pay interest on these
deposits and then they can take these
deposits and buy treasuries or other
securities and get interest on them so
they're essentially getting free
interest and that's what they use to
actually fund their operations and any
excess after funding their operations
goes back to the u.s treasury so it's
not like you know ben bernanke can can
fly around or drive a bentley or
something
and then i don't know what this is
foreign official these are small these
are nothing items so the bulk of it is
money that had been printed and that's a
liability of the federal reserve now and
then there's a little bit of deposits
from depository institutions and the
treasury has kept some money with the
federal reserve as well and then
everything left over is the equity
anyway i thought that would be pretty
neat to see that you can actually look
at what the federal reserve's balance
sheet is right now you can actually just
do a web search for it you'll find it in
a bunch of different sources and you
could actually analyze it you now have
the tools to look at that and make sense
of it and what's even more interesting
is to actually cat is to compare this
balance sheet with the current federal
reserve balance sheet and then you can
know everything that they've been up to